[Music]
i'm lauren zima we have made it to
Windsor everybody and I am in full
fascinator mode not taking this thing
off Perry and Meghan's big day is almost
here and preparations are fully underway
there's everything from tchotchkes and
flair to police and dishware
[Music]
still pretty jet-lagged so thanks Rachel
Rick we need more castle footage
sweeping shots at the castle or castle
all the castle is a castle in it should
be mostly castle I got it
he might be standing outside the castle
but people have been camping outside of
it and we found out what motivates these
very angry fans and that's a person
sleeping on the sidewalk where does the
passion come from what drives you to
camp outside the royal wedding it's hard
to say just real of the royal family
just really really no Trent I love Megan
and it's just excited to go to meet
Princess Carole are you cold
I'm Persian well I'm warming up now but
have you been sleeping out here yes
two nights tonight and you have one more
two more two more and last night was
coated with each other work yes we'll
question where do you guys go to use the
restroom a shower mcdonnell's and things
that guy hurries played the field many
times we've all waited patiently and if
these men was there soon was really be
proud of it we love love
love his braids you wore your Harry and
Megan mast in the castle who was Harry
and he was Megan that's the question
well I was Megan she was Harry but how
did you feel about mom making you be
Harry I think I look kind of like Harry
yeah I see I see it was okay they've got
their swag but we've got ours oh yeah oh
the dog is named Camila so you like my
hat you approve you are really
appropriate guys I've just had a thought
it's really hitting me right now I mean
if you're making Markel one day you're
doing yoga and the next your face is on
a shortbread tin it's weird do you think
I could slip into the wedding unnoticed
you controlling there's a lot of
military presence here
sumit yes a lot of big guns yeah yeah
yeah we can't get past that didn't you
teach me one British phrase that I
should use why I'm here in Windsor
Johnny could you show it's gonna be a
jolly good show the wedding jolly good
show a jolly good show we're about to
see the military rehearsal jolly good
show
[Music]
so far the military rehearsal has been a
lot of guns and some left-right-left but
we've heard a carriage is coming
[Music]
we could not get any closer everybody we
are right at the base of Windsor Castle
the magic of television
[Music]